Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750
with our caller from the seven zero three
area code.
Who's calling today from seven zero?
Yes, it is.
Oh, it's me.
Just a second.
Um, hi, I'm Amelia.
As I'm watching your show for a while, um,
I'm 16 years old and I'm just wondering if
you think that the current uh, media part
is just really loud in here.
Uh, I was wondering, do you think that the
way that politics are done these days with
um, more like personal attacks and more glamour
and showmanship, if that makes young people
like more apathetic or more, more apathetic
or more like passionate about starting?
It's really loud in here.
I wonder if you think that modern politics
is really damaging to young people or like
makes them more interested in the passionate
and want to fix things.
I would actually need to hear from you about
that.
I mean, when I see the way that politics has
been turned into a reality show, we have a
reality show president.
Their last date of the union was essentially
a reality show event with, you know, secret
guests coming out on announced and metals
and prizes and all sorts of stuff.
I find it absolutely disgusting and despicable.
But I mean you tell me, Amelia, if you're
16, are you finding that you are drawn in
by this sort of reality show politics or do
you find it distasteful?
I think that it makes kids my age pretty either
apathetic or more passionate.
I think [inaudible] because I think kids younger
than me might see this and start thinking
of politics as like a game.
I certainly know some of my classmates do,
but um, it just kinda makes me disgusted and
I want better cause I wasn't politically like
Sid no anything.
Cause during the entire Obama administration
he got elected when I was like, I dunno five,
right?
Yeah.
And I didn't know anything about Bush or before.
So me coming into becoming aware of the world
and be becoming aware of the world and aware
of politics and policy and then learning history
as well.
Save time.
It's kind of makes it seem like it's all always
been this way.
It is not.
It is not, and I know that it's hard to understand
that, you know, because we, in our lifetime,
we only observe a certain number of political
cycles and it can be very easy to feel like
the way things are, the way that it's always
been.
I mean, I can even tell you just in the elections
that I've observed, like when I was in high
school, George W. Bush was elected for the
first time.
Things are very different now than they were.
In some senses they are the same, but in some
senses they're very, very different.
Listen, it's great that you're politically
engaged.
It sounds crazy where you are, Emilia, so
I'm going to let you go.
All right.
But I hope you'll call back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right, good.
Thank you so much.
Great to hear from Amelia.
Just very, very loud wherever she was.